so you have uh served six terms as prime
minister over 15 years in power let me
ask you again human nature
um do you worry about the corrupting
nature of power on you as a leader on
you as a man not at all uh because I I
think that the again the the thing that
drives me is not uh is nothing but the
mission that I took to assure the uh the
survival and thriving of the state the
Jewish state that is its economic
Prosperity uh but it's security and its
ability to achieve peace with our
neighbors and I'm committed to it I
think there's still
there are many things that have been
done there are
a few big things that I can still do but
it doesn't only depend on my sense of
mission it depends on the market as we
say depends really on the will of the
Israeli voters and Israeli voters have
decided to vote for me again again even
though I wield no power in the Press
no power in in many quarters here uh and
so on nothing I mean I am probably I'm
going to be very soon the longest
serving uh prime minister in the last
half century in the western democracies
but that's not because I uh I am
masquerade political power in any of the
institutions I remember I had a
conversation with uh uh Silvio
Berlusconi who recently died and he said
to me about
I don't know 15 years ago something like
that he said so baby uh how many uh
how many uh of Israel's uh uh television
stations do you have uh and I said none
you said you have none you have do you
have I said none I have two he said no
no but what you mean you don't have any
that you control I said not only do I
have any none that I control they're all
against me so it says so how do you win
elections and you know with both hands
tied behind your back and I said the
hard way that's why you know I have the
largest party but I don't have many more
seats that I would have if I had a
sympathetic voice in the media and
Israel is until recently was dominated
completely by one side of the political
spectrum that you know often uh vilified
me not not me because they viewed me as
representing basically the conservative
voices in Israel that are majority in uh
so the idea that I'm an omnipotent
authoritarian uh uh dictator is
ridiculous I am uh I would say I'm a not
merely a champion of uh of democracy and
democratization I'm uh I believe
ultimately the decision is with the
voters and the voters even though
they've had you know they have constant
constant uh press attacks uh they have
chosen to put me back in so I don't
believe in this thing of amassing the
corrupting power of if you don't have
elections if you don't have if you
control uh the the means of influencing
the voters I'd understand uh what you're
saying but in my case it's the exact
opposite I have to constantly go in
elections constantly uh uh you know with
a disadvantage that the major media
Outlets are very
violently sometimes against me but it's
fine and I keep on winning so I don't
know what you're talking I would say the
concentration of power lies elsewhere
not here
well you have been involved in several
corruption cases how much corruption is
there in Israel and how do you fight it
in your own party and in Israel
well you should ask a different question
what's happened to these cases these
cases have uh basically are collapsing
and before our eyes the uh the uh you
know there were uh there was recently uh
an event in which the judges the three
judges in in my case called in the
prosecution and said you know your
flagship
the bribery chart so-called bribery
charts you know it's gone doesn't exist
before a single a single defense uh uh
witness was called uh and um uh it sort
of tells you that this thing is
evaporating it's quite astounding even
that I have to say was covered even by
the mainstream press uh in Israel
because it's such an earthquake so uh
you know a lot of these charges are not
a lot these charges will prove to be
nothing I always said listen I stand
before the legal process I don't claim
that um
exempt from it in any way on the
contrary I think the truth will come out
and it's coming out and we see that not
only that but with other things so I
think it's kind of instructive that you
know no no politician has been more
vilified no none has been put to such a
uh you know what is it about a quarter
of a billion
shekels were used to scrutinize me scour
my bank account sending people to the
Philippines into Mexico into Europe into
America and looking at everybody using
spyware the most advanced spyware on the
planet against my associates
blackmailing Witnesses uh uh telling
them you know think about your family
think about your wife you know you
better tell us what you want all that is
coming out of the trial so I would say
that most people now are not asking are
no longer asking including my opponents
it started trickling in as the as the
stuff comes out people are not saying
what did Netanyahu do because he
apparently did nothing
what was done to him is something that
people ask what was done to them what
was done to our democracy what was done
in the attempt to put down somebody who
keeps winning elections despite the
handicaps that I described maybe we can
maybe we can nail them by Framing him
and the one thing I can say about the
the this court trial is that things are
coming up and that's that's very good
just objective things are coming out
changing the picture so I would say the
the attempt to Brand me as corrupt is
falling on its face but the thing that
isn't being uncovered in the trial
such as the use
the use of spyware
on a politician
a politician's surroundings to try to
shake them down
in investigations
put them in flu-ridden cells for 21 days
and divide their 84 year old
mother
to investigations without cause bringing
in their Mistresses in the corridor
shaking them down
that's what people are asking that
corruption is what they want corrected